GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY I THINK
WE'RE READY TO GET STARTED.
WELCOME TO THE BUSINESS AND
PROFESSIONS COMMITTEES OVERSIGHT
HEARING FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL. THE PURPOSE OF
TODAY'S OVERSIGHT HEARING IS TO
RECEIVE AN UPDATE ON THE
ADMINISTRATION'S RECENT
CONSOLIDATION OF THE STATE'S
CANNABIS LICENSING AUTHORITIES
AND PROVIDE FOR INCREASED
LEGISLATIVE ENGAGEMENT IN THE
DEPARTMENT'S RECENTLY PROPOSED
REGULATIONS. AFTER WE HAVE
CONCLUDED THE PORTION OF THE
AGENDA FEATURING REPRESENTATIVES
OF THE DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HEAR FROM
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGH PUBLIC
COMMENT WHICH WILL TAKE WHICH
WILL. TAKE PLACE EITHER BY PHONE
OR HERE IN THE ROOM TODAY THE
CALLING NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING
IS. 877-692-8957 AGAIN THAT'S.
877-692-8957 THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE ONE
ZERO ZERO. AGAIN THE ACCESS CODE
IS. ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO ONE ONE
ZERO ZERO PUBLIC COMMENT
COMMENTED WILL BE LIMITED TO-
ONE TO TWO MINUTES FOR SPEAKER
KIND OF PENS RIGHT NOW THERE ARE
ABOUT SIX OF US IN THE HEARING
ROOM- IN WHICH CASE IT'LL BE TWO
MINUTES FOR SPEAKER IF THEY'RE
MORE FOLKS THE PARTICIPATING
IT'LL BE. A LITTLE SHORTER-
DEPENDING ON TIME ONE FINAL NOTE
WE WILL BE ADJOURNINGTHIS
HEARING NO LATER THAN ELEVEN
THIRTY AM THIS MORNING AND IN
ABOUT HALF AN HOUR I'M GONNA
HAVE TO RACE ACROSS THE STREET
TO THE CAPITOL- TO PRESENT A
BILL AND TO VOTE IN- THE PRIVACY
CONSUMER PROTECTION HEARING
THAT'S HAPPENING AT THE SAME
TIME. ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WE DID NOT HAVE THE CHANCE TO
HEAR FROM ARE WELCOME TO SUBMIT
ANY WRITTEN COMMENTS TO THE
COMMITTEE. AND TO IT TO
COLLEAGUES IF AND IF YOU WANT TO
COME DOWN AND PARTICIPATE IN
THIS ISSUE THAT YOU TALK TO ME
ABOUT ALL THE TIME. COME ON
DOWN. WITH THAT WILL KICK THINGS
OFF WITH OPENING COMMENTS FROM
OUR PRIMARY SPEAKER TODAY NICOLE
ELLIOTT. DIRECTOR OF THE TO BARK
OF THE DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS
CONTROL. NICOLE GOOD TO SEE YOU
ON THE SCREEN THANKS SO MUCH FOR
PARTICIPATING THIS MORNING. YEAH
GOOD MORNING YEAH. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. I LET ME BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND STAFF
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
AN UPDATE TO YOU ALL ON THE
DEPARTMENTS MY NAME IS NICOLE
ELLIOTT. I HAD THE HONOR OF
SERVING AS THE DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CANNABIS CONTROL.
JOINING ME TODAY ARE MY CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR RUSSIA SELAMA
AND OUR DEPUTY DIRECTOR FOR
LEGAL AFFAIRS CHEMICALS AND-
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE TODAY
TO UPDATE YOU ON THAT INCREDIBLE
PROGRESS THE DEPARTMENT HAS MADE
IN THE TEN MONTHS SINCE OUR
DEPARTMENT WAS OFFICIALLY
ESTABLISHED. AS AN ORGANIZATION
OUR VISION IS TO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA HAS A SAFE
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE
CANNABIS MARKET THAT SERVES AS
AN EXAMPLE FOR THE WORLD. WE ARE
CLEAR EYED THAT THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT WORK WE MUST DO AS
WE WORK TOWARDS THIS VISION.
SINCE DAY ONE IT'S BEEN
INCREDIBLE TO SEE THE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES A
CONSOLIDATED DEPARTMENT CAN MAKE
IN SUCH A SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
A FEW EXAMPLES OF THE STRIDES
INCLUDE THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE
DEPARTMENT'S OUTSTANDING
LEADERSHIP TEAM. THOSE WHO ARE
WORKING ALONGSIDE ME TO
EFFECTUATE THE DEPARTMENT'S
CONSOLIDATION THROUGH
IMPLEMENTING PROGRAM
EFFICIENCIES PROCESS CHANGES AND
XCELERATED RECRUITMENT EFFORTS
TO FILL VACANCIES. WITHIN TEN
WEEKS WE CONSOLIDATED THREE SETS
OF REGULATIONS INTO ONE
PROVIDING MORE CLARITY AND
CONSISTENCY TO OUR STAKEHOLDERS.
THE DEPARTMENT HAS ALSO
DISTRIBUTED A ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR GRANT PROGRAM TO
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO SUPPORT
THEM. AND THEY'RE LARGELY LEGACY
EQUITY AND SMALL. Z. IS
TRANSITION TO ANNUAL LICENSES
THESE GRANTS FIND A NUMBER OF
EFFORTS INCLUDING LOCAL
ADMINISTRATION AND A COMPLETE
MESS THE COMPLETION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEWS. CREATED
IN EQUITY WAIVER. AND WE WANT
CANNOT CONNECT A RESOURCE HUB
WITH TOOLS TO SUPPORT LICENSEE
COMPLIANCE WITH STATE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS. I'M SO PROUD OF MY
TEAMS MANY ACCOMPLISHMENTS WE'VE
BEEN ABLE AND THOUGHTFUL AND WE
ARE ENERGIZED FOR THE ENORMITY
OF OUR WORK AHEAD WE'RE
NECESSARY TO MEET OUR MISSION TO
ADVANCE TO FACILITATE A WELL
REGULATED LEGAL MARKET THAT
BENEFITS ALL CALIFORNIANS. WE
ALSO REMAIN FOCUSED ON ENHANCING
OUR WORK RELATED TO LICENSING
ENFORCEMENT COMPLIANCE AND
REGULATORY DEVELOPMENTS SO I'D
LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU A BIT
MORE ABOUT THESE EFFORTS AS WELL
. SINCE THE INCEPTION OF THE
DEPARTMENT WE'VE SEEN AN
INCREASE IN APPLICATIONS LICENSE
RENEWALS AND PROVISIONAL ST
TRANSITIONING TO ANIMALS. LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PUT IN
PLACE A RIGOROUS FRAMEWORK FOR
THE DEPARTMENT TO BEGIN PHASING
OUT PROVISIONAL LICENSES BY
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SIX.
AND BETWEEN NOW AND THEN SHIFT
PROVISIONAL ON PROVISIONAL
LICENCES TO ANIMALS. AS PART OF
THIS PHASE OUT THERE ARE SEVERAL
STATUTORY DEADLINES THAT ARE
DICTATING OUR OPERATIONAL
PRIORITIES. THESE INCLUDE ON
JUNE THIRTIETH OFTHIS YEAR THAT
WOULD BE THE LAST DATA
DEPARTMENT MAY ISSUE PROVISIONAL
LICENSES EXCLUDING. A
PROVISIONAL LICENSES FOR EQUITY
APPLICANTS AND CERTAIN SMALL
CULTIVATORS. SEPTEMBER THIRTIETH
OF THIS YEAR WILL BE THE LAST
DAY TO ISSUE PROVISIONAL
LICENSES FOR THESE SAME SMALL
CULTIVATORS. JANUARY FIRST OF
NEXT YEAR WILL BE THE SUNSETTING
OF PROVISIONAL CULTIVATION
LICENSES FOR LARGER CULTIVATION.
ARE LARGER CULTIVATORS I SHOULD
SAY THAT RESULT IN A TYPE FIVE
FIVE EIGHT OR FIVE BE LICENSE.
ON MARCH THIRTY FIRST- OF NEXT
YEAR WILL BE THE LAST DAY FOR
EQUITY OPERATORS TO APPLY FOR A
PROVISIONAL LICENSE FOR MOST
LICENSE TYPES. AND ON JANUARY
FIRST OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WILL
BE THE LAST DAY FOR OUR ENTIRE
PROVISIONAL POPULATION TO
RECEIVE RENEWALS OF ANY
PROVISIONAL LICENSE. AS THE
UPCOMING JUNE THIRTIETH
STATUTORY DEADLINE TO ISSUE
PROVISIONAL LICENSES INCHES
CLOSER AND WITH THREE THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED AND SIXTEEN
LICENSE APPLICATIONS TO REVIEW.
DEPARTMENT IS ENHANCING ITS
FOCUS ON PROCESSING THOUSANDS OF
APPLICATIONS SEEKING PROVISIONAL
LICENSURE. TO ACCOMMODATE FOR
THIS INCREASED VOLUME OF
APPLICATIONS ARE LICENSING
DIVISION HAS BEEN FOCUSING ON
HIRING ADDITIONAL STAFF AND
PRIORITIZING THE PROCESS
PROCESSING OF THESE APPLICATIONS
IN THE SHORT TERM. I LOOK
FORWARD TO PROVIDING THE
LEGISLATURE WITH A COMPREHENSIVE
REPORT ON THE STATUS OF
PROVISIONAL ANNUAL AN
APPLICATION LICENSING IN OCTOBER
OF THIS YEAR AND FURTHER MORE I
ALSO INTEND TO NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATURE. OUTSIDE OF OUR
REPORTING DEADLINES INVITATIONAL
SUPPORT IS NEEDED TO AID WITH
THE TRANSITION OF PROVISIONAL
LICENCES TO ANIMALS. ON THE
ISSUE OF ENFORCEMENT OUR
DIVISION OUR ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION I IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
TARGETING ILLEGAL CANNABIS
CULTIVATORS DISTRIBUTORS
MANUFACTURERS AND RETAILERS
OPERATING THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
OUR OFFICERS CONDUCT CRIMINAL
INVESTIGATIONS OF ILLEGAL
OPERATORS TO FULFILL THEIR
MERGING THEIR MISSION THEY WORK
CLOSELY WITH THEIR COUNTERPARTS
AT EVERY LEVEL OF GOVERNMENT
EXTENDING TO CITY COUNTY STATE
AND FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES. FOR EXAMPLE OUR
ENFORCEMENT TEAM PARTICIPATE
PARTICIPATE IN A VARIETY OF TASK
FORCES THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA TO
STRATEGICALLY TARGET ILLICIT
OPERATIONS THAT POSE SERIOUS AN
IMMENSE IMMINENT THREATS TO THE
PUBLIC THE ENVIRONMENT. AND
UNFAIR COMPETITION TO ARE
LEGITIMATE AND LICENSED
OPERATORS. OVER THE LAST TEN
MONTHS WE'VE FOCUSED ON
INCREASING HIRING IN THIS
DIVISION AND THROUGH THIS
FOCUSED EFFORT WE HAVE CUT OUR
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION VACANCY
RATE BY OVER HALF. WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED A NEW TEAM IN FRESNO
AND WE ARE IN THE PROCESS OF
ESTABLISHING TWO NEW TEAMS IN
LOS ANGELES. DUE TO THIS
INCREASE ENFORCEMENT CAPACITY WE
HAVE INCREASED OUR REACH ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND OUR ABILITY TO
ENGAGE IN MORE OPERATIONS
COMBATING THE ILLICIT MARKET.
FOR EXAMPLE. FROM JULY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE TO APRIL OF THIS YEAR
OUR ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
INCREASED THE NUMBER OF WARRANTS
THEY ISSUED BY ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED PERCENT. RESULTING IN AN
OVERT IN A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE
IN PLANTS AROUND TO CREATE A
RADIC HATED AMONG MANY OTHER
THINGS. ALSO WHERE APPROPRIATE
THE ENFORCEMENT DIVISION ALSO
WORKS WITH OUR COMPLIANCE
DIVISION TO INVESTIGATE LICENSED
OPERATORS WHO ARE WORKING IN THE
LEGAL AND ILLEGAL MARKET. OUR
COMPLIANCE DIVISION IS COMPRISED
OF A HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE NON
SWORN STAFF AND IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR ENSURING THE REGULATORY
COMPLIANCE OF LICENSED
OPERATORS. AND UP HOLDING THE
INTEGRITY OF THE LEGAL MARKET
COMPLIANCE STAFF CONDUCT DESK
AUDITS ROUTINE INSPECTIONS AND
WHERE NECESSARY THE ISSUANCE OF
CITATIONS AND A MINISTRY OF
ACTIONS TO LICENSED AND
UNLICENSED OPERATORS. TRACKING
TRACE IS ALSO IN THE COME
COMPLIANCE DIVISION- AND THE
TEAM USES IT AS A PRIMARY TOOL
FOR TREATING CANNABIS AND GOODS
FROM SEED TO SALE. OUR LICENSEES
USE THE SYSTEM TO PROVIDE THE
DEPARTMENT WITH DATA THAT WE
UTILIZE TO BETTER ENSURE
LICENSEE ACTIVITY COMPLIES. WITH
LEGAL AND REGULATORY STANDARDS
AND ALSO TO SWIFTLY PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH SHOULD WE EVER
NEED TO RECALL PRODUCTS. THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF TRACK AND TRACE
IT IS IMPORTANT TO US AND IS WHY
WE RECENTLY HELD FIELD
INSPECTIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. WITH OUR TRACK AND TRACE
OPERATOR METRIC. WE WANTED TO BE
SURE WE AND MORE IMPORTANTLY
THEY COULD HEAR DIRECTLY FROM
LICENSEES ABOUT HOW THE SYSTEM
FUNCTIONS. HOW THE FUNCTIONALITY
CAN BE IMPROVED WITHOUT
COMPROMISING THE DATA AT IN
INFORMATION THAT THE STATE IS
USING TO SUPPORT OUR COMPLIANCE
EFFORTS. IN THE LAST TEN MONTHS
THE COMPLAINT OF IT THE
COMPLIANCE DIVISION PERFORMED
APPROXIMATELY ONE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED INSPECTIONS. AND ISSUED
THREE HUNDRED AND NINETY SEVEN
NOTICES TO COMPLY TO LICENSEES
FOR VIOLATIONS UNCOVERED DURING
INSPECTIONS AS WELL AS NINETEEN
LICENSE ACTIONS RELOCATIONS
SUSPENSIONS FOR MORE SERIOUS
CASES. OUR COMPLAINTS DIVISION
WORKS COLLABORATIVELY WITH OTHER
STATE AGENCIES. AND PARTICIPATES
ON MULTI AGENCY TASK FORCES
INCLUDING THE CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM WHICH IS LED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND
WILDLIFE TO ADDRESS THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS OF THE
LEGAL CULTIVATION. WE HAVE
DEDICATED SPECIAL INVESTIGATORS
TO SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM AND ITS
OPERATIONS AFTER THE TASK FORCE
IDENTIFIES AN UNLISTED
CULTIVATION SITE AND OBTAIN
SEARCH WARRANTS ARE
INVESTIGATORS JOIN EACH
OPERATION TO INSPECT THE SITE.
AND GATHER EVIDENCE TO PURSUE
ADMINISTRATIVE OR CIVIL CASES
RELATED TO LICENSING VIOLATIONS.
AS A DEPARTMENT WE CONTINUE TO
TACKLE OUR DAY TO DAY
RESPONSIBILITIES AS WELL AS
UNIFIED REALIGN OUR BUSINESS
PROCESS USED TO MEET THE DEMANDS
OF THE WORK AHEAD OF US. WE
REMAIN VERY FOCUSED ON
ADDRESSING THE DEPARTMENTS
VACANCY RATE TO BUILD A HEALTHY
ORGANIZATIONAL CULTURE WITH A
STRONG TEAM AND WE DO THIS BY
AGGRESSIVELY RECRUITING I TO AND
ENHANCE OUR CAPACITY AND KNOWING
THAT THIS IS THE SINGLE GREATEST
THING WE CAN DO. TO MORE
EFFECTIVELY MEET OUR MANDATES
AND AVOID BARRIERS WE MAY FACE
FROM LONG TERM STAFFING
SHORTAGES. AS WE CONTINUE ALL OF
THIS WORK WE MAINTAIN A STEADY I
ON OUR FUNDAMENTAL MISSION. TO
FACILITATE AND DEVELOP A SAFE
SUSTAINABLE AND EQUITABLE MARKET
THAT IS SUPPORTED BY A SMART
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK. IT
PRESERVES THE ENVIRONMENT
SUPPORTS CONSUMER SAFETY AND
SUSTAINS BUSINESSES THAT WANT TO
DO THE SAME. RECENTLY THE
DEPARTMENT'S FORTY FIVE DAY
PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD ENDED A
FOR THE CERTIFICATION OF THE
CONSOLIDATED EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS. THIS IS A FORMAL
RULE MAKING PROCESS IS ROBUST
AND CAN SPEND EIGHT TO TWELVE
MONTHS FROM START TO FINISH. WE
ANTICIPATE THIS RULEMAKING
PACKAGE TO BE FINALIZED BEFORE
THE FALL OF THIS YEAR.
THROUGHOUT THE RULE MAKING
PROCESS STAKEHOLDERS HAVE HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE THEIR
THOUGHTS FEEDBACK AND ANY
CONCERNS ARE PROPOSED REGULATORY
CHANGES TO PUBLIC COMMENT. WHICH
CAN BE PROVIDED IN WRITING OR
VERBALLY AT OUR PUBLIC COMMENT
HEARINGS. MY STAFF HAS PROVIDED
TO THIS COMMITTEE A SUMMARY OF
THE PROPOSED REGULATORY CHANGES
THAT COMPARES HOW ARE PROPOSED
CONSOLIDATED REGULATIONS MODIFY
EXISTING REGULATIONS FOR YOUR
REVIEW ANY INFORMATION ON THE
SPECIFIC CHANGES INCLUDED IN
THIS PACKAGE. WHICH CHANGES AIM
TO STREAMLINE AND SIMPLIFY
EXISTING CANNABIS REGULATION
ENHANCE CONSUMER PROTECTIONS AND
MAKE PERMANENT CHANGES THAT ARE
CURRENTLY IN EFFECT AS EMERGENCY
REGULATIONS. WE RECEIVED NEARLY
ONE THOUSAND PUBLIC COMMENTS FOR
OUR CONSOLIDATED REGULATIONS AND
HAVE AND WILL CONTINUE TO SPEND
SIGNIFICANT TIME REVIEWING
RESPONDING AND ASSESSING THESE
COMMENTS AS WE CONSIDER WHAT
CHANGES TO SUBMIT FOR OUR
PROPOSED CONSOLIDATED
REGULATIONS. THERE IS A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF SUPPORT
FOR MANY OF THESE PROPOSED
CHANGES AND INITIAL COMMENTS WE
WERE WE- THAT WE ARE REVIEWING
CONFIRM THAT THIS SUPPORT IS
BROAD. WE ALSO RECEIVED
CLARIFYING SUGGESTIONS THAT WERE
EVALUATED TO DETERMINE IF
CHANGES IN THE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS ARE APPROPRIATE.
HE'S PROPOSED CONSOLIDATED
REGULATIONS ARE AN IMPORTANT
REFLECTION OF THE DEPARTMENTS
COULD COMMITMENT TO LISTEN
SINCERELY CONSIDER AND WHERE
APPROPRIATE BE RESPONSIVE TO THE
INPUT BY A VARIETY OF OUR
STAKEHOLDERS. BEFORE CLOSING I'D-LIKE TO PROVIDE A BRIEF UPDATE
ON CANNABIS TAX REFORM. THE
DEPARTMENT CONTINUES TO SUPPORT
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE IN ONGOING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
LEGISLATURE AND STAKEHOLDERS ON
CANNABIS TAX REFORM. WE
ANTICIPATE A PROPOSAL BEING PUT
FORWARD THAT AIMS TO GREATLY
SIMPLIFY TAX COLLECTION REDUCING
A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF BURDENS
CURRENTLY PLACED ON LICENSEES BY
THE STATE'S EXISTING TAX
FRAMEWORK. REDUCE THE TAX BURDEN
ON LICENSEES AND CONSUMERS AND
DO ALL OF THIS WITHOUT
JEOPARDIZING OUR LONG TERM
FINANCIAL COMMITMENTS TO YOUTH
PROGRAMS PUBLIC SAFETY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL RESTORATION. DCC
IS COMMITTED TO SUPPORTING
DISCUSSIONS THAT WILL RESULT IN
CANNABIS TAX POLICIES THAT
PROMOTE EQUITY AND TRANSPARENCY
AND THAT AIM TO STABILIZE THE
MARKET IN WHICH OUR LICENSEES
OPERATE. TO CONCLUDE I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
YOUR TIME AND FOR THE
LEGISLATURE'S CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP AN INTEREST IN THE
WORK OF THE DEPARTMENT. AND I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MS ELLIOTT APPRECIATE
THE VERY THOROUGH- UPDATE ON
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'VE BEEN
DOING- AND TOUCHING UPON A LOT
OF THE ISSUES- THAT THAT. MIGHT
HAVE FOLLOW QUESTIONS ON- BUT
THE GOOD NEWS IS WE'VE BEEN
JOINED BY COLLEAGUES- SO I WANT
TO TURN IT OVER WAS LONELY. FOR
A MINUTE THERE I WANT TO TURN IT
OVER TO- TO COLLEAGUES- FIRST TO
SEE IF ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS THAT THEY LIKE TO
ASK- THAT APARTMENT- HOUSE. FROM
ELEVEN- IS DOLLY SOMBER DOLLAR.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I JUST WOULD
LIKE COULD YOU PLEASE CLARIFY
THE TASK FORCE THAT YOU
MENTIONED- I HAVE A- IN MY
DISTRICT WE HAVE A LOT TO BE A
LITTLE. ILLEGAL GROWING-
DESTROYING THE ENVIRONMENT. AND
I'M VERY CONCERNED ABOUT THAT SO
I'M JUST I AM INTERESTED TO KNOW
WHAT THE TASK FORCE YOU
MENTIONED AND HOW YOU'RE
COLLABORATING. WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
. ABSOLUTELY SAID THAT TASK
FORCE AYE IT REFERRED TO IS THE
CAMPUS ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM- AND
IT IS A TASK FORCE COMPRISED
COMPRISED OF REPRESENTATIVES
FROM OUR DEPARTMENT. DEPARTMENT
OF FISH AND WILDLIFE IN THE
STATE WATER BOARD- AND OUR
DEPARTMENT CURRENTLY HAS SEVEN
POSITIONS THAT WE USE. IN OUR
COMPLIANCE DIVISION TO SUPPORT
THE OPERATIONS- OF THAT TASK
FORCE PREDOMINANTLY TO PURSUE
SIT CIVIL AND ADMINISTRATIVE
CITATIONS FOR ILLICIT ACTIVITY.
AND JUST TO BE CLEAR SORRY TO
FOLLOW UP ON THAT THE
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM CAMPUS
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM FOCUSES
SIGNIFICANTLY ON A LEGAL
PRODUCTION. AYE IMPACTING- WATER
WAYS AND OUR NATURAL RESOURCES.
SO PERHAPS TO YOUR CONCERN
ASSEMBLY WOMAN. YES SO SEVEN
SEVEN STAFF DOES NOT SEEM LIKE.
A ROBUST. I'M SURE YOU'RE DOING
ABOUT THAT WOULD THAT BE
SOMETHING THAT YOU WOULD THINK
TO EXPAND THAT- PORTION OF YOUR
DEPARTMENT TO ADD MORE STAFF TO
BE ABLE TO WHAT I'M HEARING IN
pDIFFICULT TO COORDINATE WITH
LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT THE WATER
BOARD YOU KNOW LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AS WELL AND I KNOW YOU WENT INTO
DEPTH ON LOCAL ORDINANCES VERSUS
THE STATE AND FEDERAL I KNOW
THIS IS VERY COMPLICATED. BUT
I'M WHAT DO YOU SEE MOVING
FORWARD THE FOR YOUR DEPARTMENT
SPECIFICALLY THAT YOU. COULD
HAVE JUST SUB BUILD UP SOME MORE
I MEAN WHAT WHAT DO YOU THINK
ABOUT THAT YEAH I KNOW YOU'RE
TALKING TO THE GOVERNOR ABOUT
BUDGET ISSUES. SO WHEN IT COMES
TO ARE THE WORK OF THE CANNABIS
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM I SHOULD SAY
THAT'S NOT ALL INCLUSIVE OF OUR
ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS AS A STATE.
I'M AS WELL AS SPECIFICALLY FOR
THE DEPARTMENT THE STAFF THAT
ARE SUPPORTING THE CANNABIS INFO
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM. US TO THAT
TASK FORCE OUR COMPLIANCE STAFF
SO THEY ARE NON SWORN. HOWEVER
WE DO HAVE A SWORN DIVISION AND
AS I REFERRED IT TO IN MY
TALKING POINTS AND THOSE ARE IN
MY OPENING STATEMENTS. I WE HAVE
SIGNIFICANTLY INCREASED THE
CAPACITY OF THAT DIVISION AND
WILL CONTINUE TO DO SO. DO SO
THROUGH AGGRESSIVE HIRING
EFFORTS. THAT DIVISION WORKS
VERY CLOSELY OUR IN PARTICULAR
WITH LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
SUPPORT OPERATIONS I'M ACROSS
THE STATE. I'M AN EIGHT WILL I
DON'T WANNA SPEAK FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
BUT I KNOW THROUGH EXPERIENCE
THEY DO AS WELL. I'M IN
PARTICULAR IN THE AREAS OF
ILLEGAL CULTIVATION SO IF THERE
IS A NEED FOR MORE POSITIONS TO
SUPPORT THAT WE WILL ABSOLUTELY
COME BACK AND LET THE
LEGISLATURE NOW BUT WE ARE
CURRENTLY FOCUSING ON HIRING
INTO THE EXISTING APPROVED
POSITIONS THAT WE HAVE. THANK
YOU. FAVOR MUCH I'M GOING TO
TURN OUT OF THE CONNECT THE
OVERSIGHT HEARING OVER THIS ON A
NUMBER IRWIN I'M GONNA RACE OVER
THE CAPITAL I'LL BE BACK- IF
QUESTIONS- WRAP UP IN THE
MEANTIME WE'LL GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AND AS ALWAYS IF YOU CAN
HANG OUT- I MIGHT HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU ONCE I GET
BACK- DEPENDING WHERE WE'RE AT.
THANKS SO MUCH. RIGHT MISTER
GRAYSON DID YOU HAVE SOME
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR SUBSTITUTE. THANK YOU FOR
THAT- AND BACK TO THE PUBLIC
SAFETY PART OF IT. HAS HAS THERE
BEEN AN EFFORT OR HAS THERE BEEN
OF ANY TYPE OF A SYSTEM WHERE WE
CAN COLLECT DATA ON ON PUBLIC
SAFETY ESPECIALLY ON DELIVERY-
WHAT I MEAN BY THAT IS THERE IS
A PROPOSAL IN THE REGULATIONS.
TO INCREASE FROM 500-021-0000
AND HAVE WE COLLECTED DATA ON
THE ON- THE SAFETY OF THE
DELIVERY DRIVERS. YOU HEAR A
MULTIPLE CASES ANECDOTAL CASES
WHERE- SAFETY HAS BEEN
COMPROMISED A ROBBERY OR OR
DIFFERENT THINGS LIKE THAT IN
THE MIDST OF THE DELIVERY- ARE
WE PUTTING THE DRIVERS OF
DELIVERS MORE APPAREL OR IS THAT
NOT AN ISSUE- AND- DRIVERS HAVE
BEEN AND ARE CONSIDERED SAFE
AND- AND WILL BE IN THE FUTURE.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION- YOU
KNOW DELIVERY SERVICES I AND
THEIR DRIVERS ARE ARE CRUCIAL TO
PROVIDING CONSUMERS SAFE TESTED
AT LEGAL PROCESS- AS LEGAL
ACCESS I SHOULD SAY TO PRODUCT-
WE HAVE NOT EXPERIENCED TO THE
BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE AND I WILL
OPEN IT UP TO MY COLLEAGUES TO
WEIGH IN AS WELL. I'M A TO THE
BEST OF MY KNOWLEDGE- WE HAVE
NOT EXPERIENCED ANY INCREASE- IN
PUBLIC SAFETY INCIDENTS RELATED
TO DELIVERY DRIVERS I'M SO WE DO
NOT HAVE CONCERNED THAT THAT
PROPOSED INCREASE- WILL WILL
COST PUBLIC SAFETY INCIDENTS.
I'M THAT IS SOMETHING THAT THEY
WOULD BE REQUIRED TO NOTIFY THE
DEPARTMENT OF I'M AND I DO NOT
BELIEVE WE HAVE RECEIVED ANY
NOTIFICATIONS I IN THE TIME
SINCE THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN
CREATED. THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION. YES THAT WAS THAT WAS
GOOD- WELL. IS THERE AN EFFORT
TO COLLECT THAT DATA OR IS IT
PRETTY MUCH ON A LOCAL LEVEL. SO
IF IT IF A DELIVERY DRIVER-
EXPERIENCED AN INCIDENT- OF
THEFT- OR ANY SORT OF PUBLIC
SAFETY INCIDENT WE WOULD ASK
THROUGH REGULATION I BELIEVE WE
REQUIRED THAT THEY NOTIFY THE
DEPARTMENT OF THAT INCIDENT.
ALSO THERE IS AN EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE IN PLACE TO
SUPPORT THE COLLECTION OF THAT
DATA THAT ANSWERS MY QUESTION
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WILK THANK
YOU AND YOU CAN SEE ENFORCEMENT
IS A BIG QUESTION FOR ALL OF US
AND WE'RE NOT SURE IF YOU HAVE
THE- THE APPROPRIATE RESOURCES-
IN THAT DEPARTMENT BUT I'VE A
COUPLE OF QUESTIONS. DIVING A
LITTLE BIT DEEPER SO- THAT
REGULATIONS. APPEAR TO HAVE
STRUCK THE ALLOWANCE OF A
HIGHWAY BILLBOARDS- FURTHER THAN
FIFTEEN MILES FROM THE BORDER.
BUT OBVIOUSLY WE STILL SEE A LOT
OF CANNABIS BILLBOARDS OUT
THERE- WHO ENFORCES THIS AND-
WHAT TYPE OF ACTION HAS BEEN
TAKEN AGAINST THE VIOLATORS AND
WHEN CAN WE SEE MORE ACTION.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION AND
I WILL TURN IT OVER TO ASK MY
DEPUTY DIRECTOR CLOSING AT TEN
ACROSS AND FROM OUR LEGAL
DIVISION BUT BEFORE I DO. I WILL
SAY- THE DEPARTMENT HAS A
COMPLAINTS AB PORTAL WHERE
INDIVIDUALS MAY GO IN AND SUBMIT
COMPLAINTS OF VIOLATIONS SUCH
AS- THE ONE THAT YOU IDENTIFIED
ASSEMBLY WOMAN- AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THE DEPARTMENT HAS
WORKED OUT WITH OPERATORS TO
RESOLVE. ALL OF THOSE COMPLAINTS
THAT WE RECEIVED RELATED TO
BILLBOARDS TO DATE- DEPUTY
DIRECTOR CALLS AND I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU WANT TO ADD ANY MORE TO
THAT. NO I THINK THAT'S ACCURATE
AND IT AT THIS POINT BECOMES
PRIMARILY A COMPLAINT DRIVEN
ENFORCEMENT DRIVING. AND WE DID
RUN THERE THE REGULATION THAT
WAS ACTUALLY DONE PRIOR TO THE
PENDING PACKAGE- AFTER THE COURT
ISSUED ITS RULING RELATED
SPECULATION. SELL SELL EVERY
BILLBOARD THAT HAS BEEN-
IDENTIFIED HAS BEEN REMOVED IS
THAT WHAT WE'RE HEARING. AS
ILLEGAL. I BELIEVE EVERY AT
EVERY BILLBOARD THAT HAS BEEN I
IDENTIFIED VIA A COMPLAINTS TO
THE DEPARTMENT I'M HAS BEEN
REMOVED RESOLUTION WITH THE
OPERATOR THAT SUBMITTED OR THAT
THAT POSTED THAT ADVERTISING.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND THEN-
HOW HOW CAN WE ENSURE THAT-
CANNABIS IS NOT MARKETED
ATTRACTIVELY TO- MINORS AND THEY
DOUBLE UP I THINK. WE THERE WERE
SOME SPECIFIC EXAMPLES LIKE NOT
BEING ABLE TO USE MOVIE
CHARACTERS AND I THINK THAT
THOSE HAVE BEEN REMOVED FROM THE
REGULATION SO- WHAT ARE YOU
DOING TO ENSURE THAT. WE ARE NOT
MAKING CANNABIS A TRACTIVE TO.
YOUNG PEOPLE. WE'RE DOING A
NUMBER OF THINGS- AND I'LL LET
AND I W. DIRECTOR CALLS AND
SPEAK TO THE REGULATORY
MODIFICATIONS IN THE INTENT
BEHIND THIS- REGULATIONS ARE
THAT YOU REFERRED TO. ASSEMBLY
WOMAN AND- CHIEF DEPUTY DIRECTOR
SELAMA IF YOU WANT TO ADD
ANYTHING PLEASE FEEL FREE TO. I
CAN SPEAK TO THE REGULATIONS AND
WE STILL HAVE PROVISIONS IN THE
REGULATIONS PROHIBITING
MARKETING THAT IS ATTRACTIVE TO
CHILDREN. ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WAS DONE IN THE CONSOLIDATED
REGULATIONS IS THAT WE MOVED.
THE ORDER OF WHERE SOME OF THE
THINGS WERE IN THE REGULATIONS
AND SEVEN NOW. ADVERTISING
MARKETING INCLUDING LABELS- AND
THE RESTRICTIONS ON MAKING THEM
ATTRACTIVE TO CHILDREN HAVE BEEN
CONSOLIDATED INTO ONE PLACE TO
MAKE IT MORE CONVENIENT AND MORE
CLEAR AND HE WELL AND- FINANCE.
IN ONE FIVE ZERO FOUR ZERO OF
OUR REGULATIONS AND CAN YOU ARE
THERE EXAMPLES IN THERE BECAUSE
OBVIOUSLY JUST SAYING IT'S NOT
ATTRACTIVE TO CHILDREN MIGHT.
NOT BE SUFFICIENT IF YOU DON'T
SHOW. SPECIFIC EXAMPLES. WE
CERTAINLY DO IT TALK ABOUT IT
THEY CAN'T USE ANY CERTAIN
LIKENESSES AND ALL THE ALSO AND
PROVIDE GUIDANCE IF THERE ARE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM PEOPLE OR
GETTY COMPLAINTS TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY ARE FOLLOWING THOSE
RULES. A. AS IN CONVERSATIONS
THAT I'VE HAD WITH A VARIETY OF-
STAKEHOLDERS AGAIN ON THE
ENFORCEMENT ISSUE- WE'VE HEARD
THAT THERE ARE STILL A VERY
LARGE NUMBER OF ILLEGALLY
OPERATING CANNABIS RETAILERS
AND- SO. WOULD LIKE TO KNOW
AGAIN WHAT ARE THE PLANS FOR
GREATER ENFORCEMENT AND
COORDINATION WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. THANK YOU TO SPEAK
TO THAT ISSUE ASSEMBLY WOMAN- ON
THE ISSUE OF ENFORCEMENT RELATED
TO RETAIL AND THIS IS A MULTI
PRONGED- ISSUE THAT REQUIRES A
NUMBER OF EFFORTS TO IT TO
ADDRESS THE CHALLENGES THE LEGAL
RETAIL POSE ADD TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS. ARE FIRST AND
FOREMOST I THINK I DID SPEAK TO
OUR EFFORTS RELATED TO
ENFORCEMENT- AND OUR ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION DOES FOCUS AS WELL ON
RETAIL- ILLEGAL RETAIL
SPECIFICALLY. SECOND I WOULD SAY
A SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF THE
STATE DOES NOT ALLOW FOR
LICENSED RETAIL IN THEIR FIRST
ACTIONS IN ABSENT THAT THOSE
CONSUMERS STILL DEMAND PRODUCT-
SO WE ARE WORKING DILIGENTLY TO
SUPPORT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS AS
THEY BRING ONLINE SAFE. ACCESS
FOR THEIR CONSUMERS THROUGH
LICENSED RETAIL OPERATIONS IN
THEIR JURISDICTION- BUT
ENFORCEMENT DOES REMAIN A
CENTRAL FOCUS OF THE DEPARTMENT
AS WELL AND OUR ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION I AS WELL AS OUR
COMPLIANCE DIVISION A LEGAL
DIVISION CONSTANTLY I WORK
THROUGH ADDITIONAL WAYS THAT WE
CAN GET ACT THAT ISSUE- SO THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT WE ARE FOCUSED
ON BUT WE ARE ALSO FOCUSING ON
OTHER EFFORTS. SUCH AS LICENSING
- TO ADDRESS THAT ISSUE AS WELL.
I THANK YOU I APPRECIATE IT AND
I WAS A FEW MINUTES LATE SO I
MIGHT HAVE MISSED THE BEGINNING
OF YOUR OF YOUR COMMENTS DO YOU
HAVE A SPECIFIC METRICS ON HOW
MANY ILLEGAL OPERATIONS HAVE
BEEN. BEEN CLOSED. YES WE DO- SO
FOR PURPOSES OF LOOKING AT OUR
METRICS ADDED THE TOTAL WARRANTS
THAT THE DEPARTMENT FOCUSED ON.
OUR HAS HAVE PURSUED EITHER AS
LEAD OR I IN SUPPORT FOR THE
LAST YEAR OR SO JULY THROUGH
APRIL OF THIS YEAR- ARE A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE AND IT'S
I REFERENCED IN MY OPENING
STATEMENT THAT'S AN ALMOST TWO
HUNDRED PERCENT. INCREASE OVER
THE YEAR PRIOR- AND THAT. HAS
RESULTED IN- CANNABIS VALUED AT
OVER SIX HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
BEING SEIZED OFF THE ILLEGAL
MARK. THANKS TO DO HAVE A NUMBER
OF HOW MANY STOREFRONTS ARE OR A
AS A ESTIMATE OF HOW MANY
STOREFRONTS ARE OPERATING
ILLEGALLY. SO FOR PURPOSES OF
THE WARRANTS THAT HAVE FOCUSED
ON RETAIL THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE CAN FOLLOW UP AND PROVIDE YOU
WITH THAT DATA I DON'T HAVE IT
AT MY FINGERTIPS BUT I DO KNOW
WE TRACK IT. AS IT RELATES TO
THE NUMBER OF RETAILERS
OPERATING ILLEGALLY THIS IS
SOMETHING I'VE DISCUSSED WITH
THE ASSEMBLY PREVIOUSLY THIS IS
ANISSUE OF A FLUID NATURE OF
THE END OF THE ILLEGAL MARKET
THOSE NUMBERS CHANGE OVER TIME
AS YOU SEE ENFORCEMENT AGAINST
RETAILERS OCCUR. I'M AS THEY
CHOOSE TO NOT TO RETURN OR IF
THEY DO CHOOSE TO RETURN NOW
WHERE THEY WHERE THEY CHOOSE TO
RETURN I SAW THAT SAID THE
NATURE OF THAT QUESTION OR THE
ANSWER TO THAT QUESTION IS
RATHER FLUID. THANK YOU AND THEN
JUST ONE LAST QUESTION YOU DID
MENTION TAX REFORM OF I AM ON
THE- DURING THE REVENUE TAX
COMMITTEE IT'S OBVIOUSLY WAS
GOING TO BE HEARD IN THAT
COMMITTEE AND NOW IT LOOKS LIKE
IT'S GOING TO BE IN THE- BUDGET.
A HOW WILL WE BE ABLE TO HAVE
MORE OF MEMBERS. COMMENTS ON. OR
GET THEIR INPUT INTO THOSE
REFORMS IF THE IF THIS ITEM IS
GOING TO BE IN THE BUDGET. WELL
I CERTAINLY WOULD HOPE THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS PLENTY OF
AVENUES TO WEIGH IN ON ANY BILL
THAT'S BEFORE THEM. HI IF THIS
IS A THING THAT IS PURSUED IN
THE BUDGET THAT THAT WOULD BE
THE BILL AS YOU POINTED THAT
WOULD GO THROUGH THE- BUDGET
COMMITTEE I WOULD DEFER TO YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON HOW YOU WAY AND-
OUTSIDE OF YOUR EXISTING
COMMITTEE STRUCTURE. ON BUT THAT
IS SOMETHING THAT I THINK THE
ADMINISTRATION STRONGLY SUPPORTS
IS THE ABILITY OF ALL MEMBERS OF
THE LEGISLATURE TO WAY AND
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY I THINK. THE
IDEA IS TO HAVE A BILL THAT HAS
RESOUNDING SUPPORT ACROSS THE
LEGISLATURE. THANK YOU AND IF WE
ARE GOING TO- DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT ONE
FOLLOW UP QUESTION. ONE FOLLOW
UP QUESTION YOU MENTIONED IN
YOUR OPENING REMARKS YOU HAVE A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY NINE STAFF.
AND YOU ALSO MENTIONED THAT
YOU'RE ACTIVELY- RECRUITING FOR
OPEN POSITIONS HOW MANY OPEN
POSITIONS DO YOU HAVE RIGHT NOW
IN YOUR DEPARTMENT. IS A GOOD
QUESTION AND I WILL REFER THAT
OVER TO MY CHIEF DEPUTY. I'M
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE CURRENTLY HAVE OVER
A HUNDRED ACTIVE RECRUITMENT.
AND THOSE- HUNDRED POSITIONS ARE
ACROSS ENFORCEMENT YOU CAN YOU
GIVE ME AN OVERVIEW OF WHAT OUT
THOSE POSITIONS ABSOLUTELY I'D
LOVE TO HAVE THOSE POSITIONS-
ACROSS ALL OF OUR DIVISIONS SAID
THE DEPARTMENT HAS ELEVEN
DIVISIONS AND ONE OFFICE IN THE
SPAN ACROSS ALL OF OUR DIVISIONS
. THANK YOU. OTHER DO YOU HAVE
ANOTHER FOLLOW UP- THE EVENT
OKAY SIMILAR DOLLAR THANK YOU.
WE WILL NOW GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
AND I AM NOT- SUBSTITUTE CHAIR
IRWIN I AM NOW SUBSTITUTE CHAIR
GRAYSON. AS I ALWAYS HAVE BEEN
ALL RIGHT SO WITH THAT- AND WE
ARE GOING TO GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT AT THIS TIME AND OTHER
ANY MEMBERS IN THE CHAMBER THAT
WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT PLEASE
COME TO THE- MICROPHONE. PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN BIRDS RAND MARTIN ON
BEHALF OF THE PARENT COMPANY
BETTER KNOWN AROUND THE CAPITOL
AS KHALIFA- BASED OUT OF SAN
JOSE BUT WITH OPERATIONS ACROSS
THE STATE- I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT
ONE PARTICULAR ISSUE THAT. HAS
SOME ANXIETY AMONG FOLKS IN THE
IN THE IN THE COMMUNITY AND
INDUSTRY- I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS FROM THE DIRECTOR I
KNOW THEY'VE BEEN DOING A- GREAT
JOB RECENTLY RELATIVE TO-
TRANSITIONING FOLKS FROM
PROVISIONAL TO ANNUAL LICENSES.
SO MUCH BETTER THIS YEAR THAN
THEY HAVE DONE IN THE PAST AND
WE REALLY APPLAUD THAT EFFORT.
AND WE ARE STILL CONCERNED
BECAUSE OF THE STATUTORY
DEADLINES FOR THOSE TRANSITIONS
TO HAPPEN ESPECIALLY FOR LARGER
CULTIVATORS LARGER CULTIVATORS
HAVE TO- HAVE TO BE. WRITTEN IN
THERE THE LAST TIME THAT THEY
CAN BE RENEWED FOR THEIR. YOU'D
AFTER JANUARY FIRST OF I'M SORRY
NEXT YEAR- AFTER JANUARY FIRST
OF TWENTY TWENTY FOUR SO FOR
EXAMPLE- TEPCO HAS FOR
CULTIVATION LICENSES IN THE CITY
OF SAN JOSE. ALL OF THEM
PROVISIONAL ALL OF THEM WILL BE
RENEWED- ON MAY TWENTY FOURTH OF
THIS YEAR. THEY NEED TO
TRANSITION TO AN ANNUAL LICENSE
BY MAY TWENTY FOURTH OF NEXT
YEAR OTHERWISE THEY GO OUT OF
BUSINESS- AND SO IT'S VERY
CONCERNING TO US. NOT TO THE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT TRYING TO GET
THEIR- BUT THERE ARE ACCORDING
TO THEIR DATABASE- THEY'RE
CURRENTLY ABOUT SEVEN THOUSAND
CULTIVATION LICENSES. THAT STILL
NEED TO BE TRANSITION FROM
PROVISIONAL TO ANNUAL I'M IN
ANOTHER THREE THOUSAND- OF OTHER
KINDS OF LICENSES AGAIN
ACCORDING TO THEIR DATABASE THAT
NEED TO BE TRANSITION. THAT'S AN
AWFUL LOT OF WORK THAT NEEDS TO
BE ACCOMPLISHED I JUST WANNA
MAKE SURE THE LEGISLATURE IS
AWARE- SO THAT IF THERE IS A-
RISK OF LOSING. LICENSES AND
LOSING JOBS LOSING LEGAL-
PROVIDERS OF CANNABIS- THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN STEP UP AND MAKE
SURE THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- SO IT LOOKS LIKE WE JUST
STARTED PUBLIC COMMENT WHY DON'T
WE- KEEP GOING WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT AND THEN I MIGHT HAVE
SOME QUESTIONS FOR FOLKS- WHAT'S
MORE COMMON IS OVER SO. IS THERE
ANYBODY ELSE IN THE HEARING ROOM
WHO WANTS TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMMENT- ON ON THIS ISSUE I
DON'T SEE ANY SO WHILE WE TAKE
THE PHONE LINES- IT AT THE- MR
OR MADAM OPERATOR IS THERE
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT.
I THINK WE'VE GOT TIME SO FOLKS
WANT TO GO UP TO TWO MINUTES
THAT'LL WORK- FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT- FOR THE DEPARTMENT.
THANKS OKAY AND THANK THANK YOU
ECONOMIC ALLIANCE COULD NOT MAKE
A PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS.
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME AGAIN IT'S
ONE ZERO.
NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS IN
QUEUE AT THIS TIME THAT. IS NOT
WHAT I WAS EXPECTING BUT I
APPRECIATE IT- SO WHY DON'T WE
WELL YES YEAH I DO HAVE A COUPLE
OF COMPANY OPERATE HERE GIVE ME
JUST A MOMENT ALL RIGHT WE'LL
THINK WILLING. TO TAKE. AS GREAT
THANKS. YOUR.
ALL RIGHT WELL FIRST BUT A LINE
NUMBER ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M SORRY LET LINE NUMBER TWELVE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
GERMANY COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS CHRISTY HUDDLE PARK HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE UFCW WESTERN
STATE COUNCIL AND ARE ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND NUMBERS
. THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WORK IN
THE CANNABIS INDUSTRY FIRST ME
LIKE IT'S BREASTS ARE PRECISION
TO DCC WHOSE WORKED TIRELESSLY
TO STREAMLINE LICENSING AND
ENFORCEMENT THROUGH
CONSOLIDATION. AND MADE STRIDES
IN COMBATING THE ILLICIT MARKET
HOWEVER YOU HAVE TO W. WAS VERY
DISAPPOINTED TO SEE THE DCC BY
PASSED THE LEGISLATURE IN RAPE
CASE LIMIT TO TEN THOUSAND.
WITHOUT INCLUDING CRITICAL
WORKER AND CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
THAT UFCW NEGOTIATED INTO AB TEN
FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY. IF YOU W. REMAIN
CONCERNED ABOUT THE DELIVERY
DRIVERS MANY OF WHOM WE
REPRESENT. TAKING ON INCREASED
RISK. YEP YEP. NEGOTIATED THE
INCLUSION OF THE CARD HEALTH
INSURANCE REQUIREMENTS STRICTER
STANDARDS ON THE CONDITION OF
THE DELIVERY VEHICLE AND MOST
IMPORTANTLY TRACKING TRAITS
REQUIREMENTS AT THE FINAL MILE
DELIVERY COMPONENT. UPW STRONGLY
URGES THE DCC AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ADOPT AB TEN
FOURTEEN INCLUDING THE WORKER
AND CONSUMER SAFETY MEASURES.
WHEN SEEKING TO INCREASE CASE
LIMITS. TO TEN THOUSAND THANK
YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. AND THEN NEXT LINE SIX
PLEASED AHEAD. YES THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBER OF ANY CHANGE CAN FINALLY
HAPPENED BACK CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE OVERSIGHT HEARING
TODAY AND- APPRECIATE THE
COMMENTS MADE BY DIRECTOR
ELLIOTT I WANT TO ECHO CONCERNS
RAISED BY MY COLLEAGUE RAND
MARTIN ON BEHALF OF KHALIFA ACT
SHE CA CONTINUES TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT- THE PROVISIONAL LICENSE
BECAUSE AND THE PENDING
DEADLINES AND SO WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO- MONITOR AND WORK
WITH OUR MEMBERS TO ENSURE THAT
NOBODY FALLS OUT. OF THE SYSTEM
WHILE THEIR APPLICATIONS ARE
BEING PROCESSED WE ARE ALSO AT A
VERY EAGER TO CONTINUE
DISCUSSIONS AROUND TAX REDUCTION
AND REFORM THE ADMINISTRATION
HAS COMMUNICATED SOME GENERAL
PRINCIPLES TO US AND WE ARE
WORKING INTERNALLY AND SHE CRAFT
A PHYSICIAN WHEN THINGS ARE IN
WRITING BUT WE CONTINUE TO
MAINTAIN. THAT THE INDUSTRY DOES
NEED- COMPREHENSIVE REFORM AND
REDUCTION THAT IS ATTACHED TO
STAND BACK AND NOT SHORT TERM SO
WE BELIEVE OUR COMMENTS WILL
LIKELY REFLECT THAT- AND THEN
LASTLY WE CONTINUE TO
APPRECIATE. THE WORK THAT OUT
AND THE REGULATORY PACKAGE THAT
WAS PUT FORWARD AND WE ENCOURAGE
ADDITIONAL DIALOGUE AND
TRANSPARENCY GOING FORWARD
STROKES I WANT TO THANK THE
DIRECTOR AND THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING.
OUR WORK WITH THE PC. THANK YOU
VERY. WE HAVE ONE MORE HERE WITH
THIS JUST A MOMENT.
A COUPLE MORE HERE Q. AND UP
HERE JUST GALLAGHER GIVEN THEIR
ONLINE AND- THANKS. GEORGE
WALKER I WILL GO LINE FIFTEEN
NON PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
BREAK LET THAT THE WITH APEX
GROUP ON BEHALF OF PURELY TEMP
PERFECT UNION TO VERTICALLY
INTEGRATED CANNABIS COMPANIES-
WE'D LIKE TO ECHO THE COMMENTS
MADE BY MR MARTIN IN AMY JENKINS
REGARDING PROVISIONAL LICENSES
AND APPRECIATE. ALL THE WORK AT
THAT'S BEEN DONE BY THE
DEPARTMENT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
. ANEXO GOT LINE SIXTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING THIS IS
PAMELA LOPEZ WITH K. THREE
CONSULTING ON BEHALF OF THE
SHRINE GROUP WE APPRECIATE ALL
OF THE WORK OF THE DCC TO UPDATE
THEIR REGULATIONS AND UNDERSTAND
THAT IT IS A CHALLENGING
PROCESS- TO GET THROUGH
EVERYTHING AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE C. C. AND
THEIR LEADERSHIP. ECCLES TRYING
GROUP IS CONCERNED ABOUT
PROPOSED SECTION ONE SEVEN THREE
ZERO THREE POINT ONE. ADDITIONAL
REQUIREMENTS FOR INHALED
PRODUCT- SPECIFICALLY AT THE
PROPOSAL WOULD ELIMINATE ALL AND
HEALTH PRODUCTS THAT ARE NOT ON
AN FTA LET. OF CONSUMABLE
INHALABLE PRODUCTS. AND WE
RESPECTFULLY NOTE THAT THIS IS A
LOWER MAP SAID IN TERMS OF
POLICY IMPLEMENTATION. FOR
GETTING RID OF THE FOR THE CIVIC
PRODUCTS THAT ARE KNOWN TO BE
DANGEROUS FOR THE PUBLIC RATHER
THAN WORKING TOWARD A LIST OF
ALLOWABLE INHALABLE PRODUCTS.
BASED ON AN FDA LEFT FOR WHICH
THERE IS NO PROCESS TO- UP TO
DATE WITH CANNABIS INGREDIENTS
BECAUSE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DOES NOT RECOGNIZE CANNABIS. AS
AN ALLOWABLE SUBSTANCE WE HUMBLY
ENCOURAGE THE DEPARTMENT OF
CANNABIS CONTROL TO ADOPT
REGULATIONS TO PRIORITIZE
POLICIES- THAT A DRAFT
ELIMINATING PRODUCT INGREDIENTS
THAT ARE KNOWN TO BE UNSAFE.
THESE INCLUDE VITAMIN E. ACETATE
POLYETHYLENE GLYCOL. AND MEDIUM
CHAIN TRIGLYCERIDE TRIGLYCERIDES
OR MCT OIL WE BELIEVE THAT
FOCUSING ON GETTING THESE OUT OF
PRODUCT AND DOING IT IN A WAY
THAT THE PUBLIC IS VERY AWARE
OF. WILL INCREASE PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE IN THE DCC REGULATORY
PROCESS. AND PUBLIC CONFIDENCE
IN PAYING SLIGHTLY MORE FOR
LICENSE LEGAL REGULATED CANNABIS
PRODUCTS. WHICH ARE CLEARLY
KNOWN TO BE STATES BECAUSE THE
STATE HAS A PROCESS OF
ENFORCEMENT IN PLACE. TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. YOU
CAN GO TO LINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND YOUR LINES UP. SEVENTEEN YOU
MAY HAVE YOUR LINE NEEDED. I
WOULDN'T GO TO LINE EIGHTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
DAVID KITANA WOULD BE CANNABIS
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION. AND I
WOULD LIKE TO THINK DIRECTOR
ELIA AND HER STAFF- FOR WORKING
WITH US TO TRY AND CREATE A
SEPARATE CATEGORY TYPE. FOR
CANNABIS BEVERAGES WE WOULD LIKE
TO IT JUST YET EMPHASIZE HOW
IMPORTANT THIS IS CANNABIS
BEVERAGES ARE VERY VERY
DIFFERENT. AS DAN- EDIBLE AND-
AGAIN WE JUST WHICH TO CONTINUE
WORKING WITH HER SO THAT WE
COULD ARE PERHAPS X.-PEDITE-
GIVING BACK PURCHASE A SEPARATE
CATEGORY TYPE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. AND LOCAL BACK WHAT TRYLINE
SEVENTEEN AGAIN HERE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CAN YOU HAVE YOUR MEAT ON
BY CHANCE. AND NOT GETTING ANY
AUDIO FROM SEVENTEEN. SEVENTEEN
FEEL FREE TO SUBMIT ANY COMMENTS
THROUGH THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE
PORTAL IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM DURING THE HEARING
TODAY. YEAH WE DO HAVE THEIR
LINE UP IS NOTHING COMING FROM
THAT DEPRIVE TWICE HERE SO THERE
MIGHT BE SOMETHING WRONG. ARE
NONE NONE FURTHER AT THIS TIME
GREAT THANKS SO MUCH- SO IF THE
FOLKS FROM THE DEPARTMENT ARE
STILL AVAILABLE- I WAS ASSUME
THEY ARE EVEN I'M LOOKING AT A
BLANK SCREEN. WE'RE HERE AWESOME
THANKS- SO I UNDERSTAND THAT
THAT MANY OF THE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS ARE TO IMPLEMENT
CONSOLIDATION- BUT OBVIOUSLY
THERE'S A LOT OF NEW POLICY IN
THERE TOO SO- ONE QUESTION I WAS
TO THE DEPARTMENT CONSIDER
WHETHER CERTAIN POLICY CHANGES
WERE. BETTER LEFT TO THE
LEGISLATURE TO THIS TO DECIDE
AND THAT DOES A SPECIFIC EXAMPLE
WHICH WAS BROUGHT UP EARLIER. I
KNOW ONE OF THE PROPOSED
REGULATIONS DOUBLES THE CASE
LIMITED TEN THOUSAND DOLLARS-
THIS POLICY CHANGES ALSO IN A
BILL CURRENTLY CARRIED BY ONE OF
MY COLLEAGUES. THAT ALSO
INCLUDES A NUMBER OF WORKER
PROTECTIONS THAT ARE NOT
CURRENTLY INCLUDED IN THE RAGS.
IS THE DCC CONSIDERING INCLUDING
SOMEONE PROTECTIONS THAT WERE
NEGOTIATED THROUGH THE MORE
TRANSPARENT LEGISLATIVE PROCESS. EVEN THAT QUESTION CHAIR THE
MOST RECENT MODIFICATIONS
PROPOSED IN OUR REGULAR
RULEMAKING PACKAGE REPRESENTS
MODIFICATIONS FOR CLARIFICATIONS
THAT IN A NUMBER OF INSTANCES.
STAKEHOLDERS HAVE BEEN
REQUESTING WE CONSIDER OVER THE
COURSE OF SEVERAL YEARS THESE
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE WHAT YOU
HEARD INGREDIENT RESTRICTIONS
INSPIRED. BY CALIFORNIA'S
EXPERIENCE WITH THE PEIPING
CRISIS OR A VALLEY. WHICH TOOK
PLACE IN TWENTY NINETEEN. HI TWO
MODIFICATIONS THAT RESULTED FROM
OUR COLLECTIVE EXPERIENCES
DURING KOBE. THE LEGISLATURE IS
YOU KNOW VERY WELL AS VESTED
WITH MASTER'S ALREADY TO ENHANCE
REFINE OR CHANGED THE SCOPE OF
OUR POLICIES AND NOTHNG ABOUT
THAT AT THIRTY IS LIMITED. BY
OUR RULE MAKING PROCESS IT'S MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THAT IN
MCCARTY BELL IS STILL MOVING
THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS.
AND SO I WON'T SPEAK
SPECIFICALLY TO THAT BILL BUT I
DO APPRECIATE. AND THE
LEADERSHIP OF THAT AUTHOR IN
WORKING ON THOSE VERY
CHALLENGING ISSUES. THANK YOU.
FOR THAT OUT OF YOUR BECAUSE OF
ANY OTHER COMMENTS OR NO. THE
WEIRD WAY TO CONDUCT A HEARING-
GREAT THANK YOU. BURFICT THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND- YEAH AND I
ALSO APPRECIATE THE RECOGNITION
YOU KNOW THAT THERE ARE- SIR IS
AN IMPORTANT POLICY ISSUES- YOU
KNOW MAKE THEIR WAY THROUGH THE
LEGISLATURE AND- THAT Y'ALL ARE
COGNIZANT OF THAT AND KEEPING
THAT IN MIND IS AS YOU CONTINUE
THREE EURO MAKING PROCESS AND
WILL CONTINUE THROUGH OUR
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS- IN REGARDS
TO- PROVISIONAL LICENSES AND I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN ALREADY A LOT
OF DISCUSSION ABOUT THIS YOU YOU
STARTED OFF- YOU KNOW YOU'RE
TALKING POINTS REALLY DIVING
INTO THIS- BUT I GUESS. YOU KNOW
. SORTING THROUGH A LOT OF THE
DIFFERENT CONCERNS AND FACTORS
WHAT CAN WE BE DOING BETTER TO
HELP GET EVERYONE ON AN ANNUAL
LICENSE- AND WE GET WE FOR
DIFFERENT FIGURES. ABOUT HOW
MANY PEOPLE ARE STILL ON
PROVISIONAL LICENSES I KNOW
YOU'VE PROVIDED ALL THE
DIFFERENT DEADLINES UPCOMING
DEADLINES. I TO TRANSITION FOLKS
BUT BUT WHAT CAN WE DO BETTER-
SET TO HELP GET EVERYONE ON AN
ANNUAL LICENSE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU FOR THAT QUESTION I THINK
IT'S A VERY BIG QUESTION AND TO
BE COMPLETELY HONEST- YOU KNOW.
AS I ALLUDED TO AYE WE'RE
PROCESSING THOUSANDS OF
APPLICATIONS- AND AT THE SAME
TIME CONVERTING PROVISIONAL
LICENSEES. I TO ANNUAL LICENSES.
I'M AND ONE THING THAT HAS
SIGNIFICANTLY HELPED- OVER THE
PAST COUPLE OF MONTHS REALLY. I
IS THE ONE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR LOCAL JURISDICTION
EXISTENCE GRANTS WHICH WILL
REALLY AIMING TO HELP LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WITH. A
SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
PROVISIONAL LICENSES- MOVE
THROUGH THAT LOCAL PROCESS AS
WELL AS MEET THIS NET SORT OF.
HI BAR OF SEQUEL. ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT LICENSE I THINK THE
BEST THING THAT WE CAN
COLLECTIVELY DO A WHEN IT COMES
TO ADDRESSING THE CHALLENGERS AT
CHALLENGES OF ATTAINING ANNUAL
LICENSURE. IS TO LOOK AT THE
ANNUAL LICENSING PROCESS AND
FIGURE OUT WHERE WE CAN REMOVE
DUPLICATION IF APPROPRIATE
BETWEEN LOCAL AND STATE
LICENSING PROCESS SEES. AND
START TO DO A REALLY DEEP DIVE
ON HOW WE CAN FURTHER STREAMLINE
THE ANNUAL LICENSING PROCESS AND
THAT WILL REQUIRE. AYE
ENGAGEMENT WITH THE LEGISLATURE
IN AND KEEP US IN THE LOOP AS
YOU IDENTIFY SOME OF THOSE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STREAMLINING
ABSOLUTELY ABSOLUTELY- WHAT'S
THAT SPEAKING OF DIE CUT.
APPLICATIONS AND PROCESSES AND
TIMELINES WHAT'S THE CURRENT
PROCESS AND TIMELINE FOR NEW
LICENSE APPLICATION. SO I THINK
THAT THAT TIMELINE VARIES
BROADLY- DEPENDING ON THE LOCAL
JURISDICTION PROCESS OF THE
LICENSE TYPE. AND THE
THOROUGHNESS OF THE APPLICATION
SO- I'M VERY THOROUGH
APPLICATION OUT WITH A LOCAL
JURISDICTION I THAT HAS THE
ABILITY TO MOVE THEIR PERMITS
AND SEQUEL PROCESS QUICKLY I
WITH A MORE SIMPLE LICENSE TYPE
IS ANYWHERE FROM SIXTY TO NINETY
DAYS. GOTCHA BUT IT CAN GO UP TO
WHAT'S WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE
HIGH END. WELL WE STILL HAVE
LICENSES WHO ARE IN PROVISIONAL
LICENSURE I SO I THINK THAT
SPEAKS TO THAT QUESTION THERE
ARE SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF
LICENSES SOCKS THAT WERE STOCKS
IN I THINK I WOULD SAY TWENTY
NINETEEN. ARE THAT ARE STILL ON
PROVISIONAL LICENSURE AND HAVE
NOT YET EIGHTEEN IN IN ALL SO I
CAN BE THAT LONG AND LONGER
GOTCHA THANK YOU. SOME JUDGE I
KNOW THERE'S BEEN LOTS OF A
CONVERSATION ABOUT FORSMAN AND
LOTS OF CONCERNS RAISED BY
COLLEAGUES ABOUT FORSMAN MOST OF
WHICH HAPPENED WHILE I WAS NOT
HERE- BUT LET ME TO SECOND YOU
KNOW KIND OF THE CONCERNS- AND
QUESTIONS AND ISSUES THAT
COLLEAGUES RAISED- WHAT I GUESS
MY QUESTION IS HOW MANY INFORMED
YOU YOU MIGHT ALREADY ANSWER
THIS BUT HOW MANY ENFORCEMENT
CASES HAS THE DEPARTMENT TAKEN
SINCE CONSOLIDATION. SO THE
DEPARTMENT HAS TAKEN OFF FROM
WITHIN THE ENFORCEMENT DIVISION
EITHER LED OR SUPPORTED A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY NINE WARRANTS
WHICH IS AN ALMOST 2100%
INCREASE. UP FROM THIS YEAR.
OVER LAST YEAR GOTCHA. IT'S. AND
YOU TOUCHED UPON- AND I DON'T
KNOW IF ANYBODY TO ASK QUESTIONS
ABOUT IT BUT YOU TOUCH ON TAX
REFORM OBVIOUSLY TAX REFORM IS.
THE EIGHT HUNDRED POUND GORILLA
IN THE ROOM- YOU KNOW SOMETHING
THAT'S IMPORTANT THAT THAT I
HEAR ABOUT FROM. EVERY KIND OF
STAKEHOLDER IN THIS IN THIS
SPACE. WHAT IS NECESSARY TO MAKE
A DEAL HAPPEN IS IT FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION'S KIND OF POINT
OF VIEW IS A TOTAL CONSENSUS
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS. OR IS IT
JUST GETTING ENOUGH VOTES IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO IT TO GET- TAX
REFORM ACCOMPLISHED. WONDERFUL
QUESTION I DON'T WANNA SPEAK UP
WE HAVE THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
BUT I WILL SAY- JUST HAVING
WORKED ON. YOU KNOW MAJOR
POLICIES LIKE THIS IN THE PAST
OBVIOUSLY HAVING UNANIMITY OF
SUPPORT IS IDEAL. VERY
CHALLENGING TO DO ON SUCH A
COMPLEX BIG POLICY ISSUE. I SO
OF COURSE I THINK IT WOULD BE
WONDERFUL TO SEE EVERYBODY-
SUPPORT A TAX REFORM PROPOSAL.
AND IT CAME OUT OF THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE I DON'T KNOW
IF THEY ALL WELL- BUT THAT'S THE
NATURE THAT'S NATURE BIG POLICY.
IT IS IT IS AND I KNOW THERE'S A
LOT OF A LOT OF DESIRE THAT A
LOT OF DIFFERENT IDEAS. AMONGST
MY COLLEAGUES- YOU KNOW WHO WERE
THERE ALREADY TO GO F SOMETHING
CAN'T GET ACCOMPLISHED- SO IS SO
YOU KNOW HOPEFULLY THEY
HOPEFULLY WERE ABLE TO GET
SOMETHING ACCOMPLISHED THIS
YEAR. TO PROVIDE THE RELIEF THAT
I KNOW A LOT OF FOLKS ARE.
LOOKING FOR- SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT. LEGAL
OPERATORS AND CONTINUE TO MAKE
IT HARDER FOR ILLEGAL OPERATORS
TO. OPERATE IN CALIFORNIA- SO
THAT IS ALL OF THOSE ARE ALL THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE WANTED JUST
QUICKLY LOOK TO CALL TO SEE IF
ANY FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS. FROM
ANYBODY LOOKING TO MY LEFT.
LOOKING TO MY RIGHT. DON'T SEE
ANYBODY. OUR WALL WE'RE GONNA
EVERYONE CAN GET TO LUNCH AN
HOUR EARLIER THAN THEY EXPECTED-
THANK YOU MS ELLIOTT- AND INTO
YOUR COLLEAGUES FOR-
PARTICIPATING IN THIS MORNING'S
OVERSIGHT HEARING THANK YOU. FOR
ALL THE WORK THAT YOU'VE BEEN
DOING I KNOW IT'S BEEN A LOT-
AND THAT THERE'S- STILL A LOT TO
GO- BUT APPRECIATE ALL THAT
YOU'VE ACCOMPLISHED SO FAR AND
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
TOGETHER- TO ACCOMPLISH MORE. IN
THE COMING MONTHS AND YEARS.
THANK YOU CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO
ENTIRE FOR HAVING US HERE TODAY
WE PREACH WE APPRECIATE THE
PARTNERSHIP. PRUDENTIAL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. GREAT AND WITH
THAT ARE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
HEARING IS ADJOURNED THANKS.